we don't know yet what all of the  collusion was between the city and the  federal government but this certainly  feels like retribution because we have  here collective that was fighting with  the city of water basically land-use in  business license issues out really local  issues and all of a sudden the federal  government shows up to raid the facility  and so it just feels like some sort of  collusion and retribution as if the city  maybe is encouraging the feds to come in  and take this kind of action and this  one be the first time we saw that in  medical cannabis it's really a shame  because if the cities are going to  regulate and our city councils and our  courts and our legislature are going to  figure out medical marijuana and do it  the way voters want we've got to get the  feds to back off and give us that space